for the first time since the beginning
of the pandemic punthe is getting ready
for a trip to Thailand he says he's
Overjoyed China has ended its strict
zero covered border controls
absolutely I'm so passionate about it
and because I've been stuck here for
like three years the urge is so strong I
really want to travel abroad like at
least to Thailand somewhere easy
from Sunday those returning to China no
longer have to undergo quarantine the
change has sparked a surge in travel
bookings Japan South Korea and the
United States are among popular
destinations Thailand has topped the
list staff in this Bangkok hotel are
looking forward to welcoming back
Chinese tourists 5 million are expected
this year
Chinese visitors are vital for the
tourism industry throughout the country
they not only spend money in Bangkok but
they usually travel Nationwide
China's borders with Hong Kong have also
been reopened these passengers are among
the first to cross without needing to
isolate at a government facility
this weekend also marks the beginning of
Junoon the travel period leading up to
Lunar New Year Chinese Railway
departments expect 2 billion trips to be
made over the next few weeks many by
migrant workers who are unable to travel
home in previous years due to strict
zero covert policies
but widespread covid-19 infections have
prompted the government to issue
guidelines cautioning against spreading
the virus in rural areas
governments abroad have also raised
concerns with more than a dozen
countries including the United Kingdom
France and Australia imposing
restrictions on passages from China
pongfei says he'll steer clear of those
countries for now and is just relieved
that China's days of global isolation
seem to be ending
katrinau al-jira Beijing